[Musik]
dieser du hast du uns leid wir wollten
nicht vorher die stellen nein es ist nur
mein arbeitsplatz macht mich total
verrückt ich weiß nicht wie ich das
alles schaffen soll
solltest du nicht ein paar sprachkurse
absage montag privatstunden das ist doch
unglaublich stressig wenn du zu jedem
einzelnen musst das ist kein stress für
mich außerdem mit leben sollen sie denn
sonst lernen in der gruppe auch zu zweit
du könntest dich auch mit ihnen in der
bibliothek treffen oder ins café gehen
ich weiß ich muss irgendwas reduzieren
aber ich bin niemanden im stich lassen
diese ich weiß ich weiß ich denke
darüber nach aber jetzt muss ich erstmal
neues material für die nächste
förderstunde zusammensuchen
was ist das thema es geht um berufe so
wo sind jetzt meine notizen jan doch
eben noch hier gelegen oder habe ich in
der küche liegen lassen okay ja
aufzusuchen
ich hatte nie b
[Musik]